My name is Jason, CEO of Veewo
We have been dedicated to making small but enjoyable games
since we started the company in 2011
Some of our games were officially promoted by Google Play
like Dark Slash:Hero and Just Get 10
and have been well received globally
Our latest leading game is a casual action game
Super Phantom Cat
Thanks to Google Play game services
we are able to reach as many Android users as possible
The game got 870K visits and 120K downloads within a week
This is an exceptional achievement which we wouldn’t have imagined before
We decided to support Android TV at a very early stage
Now 10% of our users play this game on TV
As game makers who love TV games in our youth, we are very proud.
I’m Yop, producer of Veewo
Beta testing and fast Iterations
have allowed us to achieve success on Google Play
Since we implemented Beta Testing
the user score increased steadily from 4.1 to 4.6
Thanks to the group-distribution model
we are able to gather precise feedbacks
before we make any bold updates
It makes our game quality very stable
Google Play helps us keep the promise of making best games
Admob is our primary revenue driver
Our profit keep on rising
thanks to its high display rate
Our income has increased by dozens of times in the past 4 years
Google Play also allows us to reply to user comments in the games reviews
This feature not only helped us reduce 31% user loss
but also made some players became our friends
Players want to talk with developers, now we are more sure of it
Promotion Codes give us a new way of operation
Google Play In-app Promotions allow us to reward users anytime, anywhere
We can give rewards in forms of a well-designed virtual character, or a level with special content
Google Play smooths the communication between us and players
and helps us improve the game and its operation more easily
Now 70% of our business and players comes from the Android platform
and this growth has made us more confident about the future of our company
We want to maintain our team philosophy into the future:
Bringing wonderful gaming experiences to our players